Actor Cuba Gooding Jr. has had some
ups and downs in both his professional
and personal life. As with many Oscar winners,
the road toward continued success is often
paved with lots of twists and turns. Here's why
Hollywood won't cast Cuba Gooding Jr. anymore.
To get the elephant out of the room: The most
obvious reason Cuba Gooding Jr. isn't being
sought out for roles anymore is that numerous
women have accused him of sexual misconduct.
It started in June of 2019, when
USA Today reported that Gooding was
being investigated for allegedly groping a
woman while drunk at a bar in New York City.
Gooding was later arrested after turning himself
in to the NYPD, as USA Today later confirmed.
He was eventually released
pending a further trial.
In October of that same year, The New York
Times reported that Gooding was indicted on
a separate sexual abuse charge. Though details
about the new allegations weren't released,
they were serious enough that they
delayed the trial for the June incident.
The same New York Times report also noted that
Gooding denied all allegations against him,
and that his lawyers had tried unsuccessfully
to get the original charges dismissed.
Some believe the trouble began earlier than 2019.
Page Six reported that ever since Gooding's
divorce from his high school sweetheart,
Sara Kapfer, in 2014, the actor has spent his free
time clubbing, partying, and drinking heavily,
while displaying some of the questionable
behavior detailed in the assault allegations.
"I was in a club the other night, broke my ankle."
"What are you talking about?"
"Well, I sprained it."
Not long after the second woman
made charges against Gooding,
Page Six reported that three more women
had come forward to accuse the actor of
misconduct. The report stated that these
new allegations dated back as far as 2008,
and included instances of Gooding groping two of
the women in similar ways on separate occasions.
By the end of 2019, NBC News reported that the
number of women accusing Gooding of misconduct
had grown to 22, which included
an additional seven women coming
forward with detailed stories that
involved instances of forced kissing
and Gooding giving graphic depictions of sexual
acts, among other inappropriate behaviors.
The coming year proved to be even worse for
Gooding, as CNN reported the number of accusers
had grown to a staggering 30 women by August
2020. Gooding also officially got charged with
three counts of forcible touching and three counts
of sexual abuse. He still denies all wrongdoing.
As of the time of the CNN report,
Gooding's defense was working to
undermine the credibility of the accusers
by using their past statements against
them and to question the procedural
propriety of the police investigation.
In addition to the multiple criminal
accusations, two women have filed civil
suits against Gooding. In August 2020, The
New York Times reported that a lawsuit was
filed against the actor by a woman accusing
him of sexually assaulting her twice in 2013.
The lawsuit stated that the woman, referred
to as Jane Doe, met Gooding at a Greenwich
Village restaurant, and the actor invited
her to have drinks with him at a hotel in
SoHo. Gooding eventually invited her to his
hotel room; when the woman tried to leave,
she said Gooding attacked and raped her.
This follows a different lawsuit that
was filed earlier in 2019 by one of
the many women who accused Gooding
of groping. According to Page Six,
bartender Natasha Ashworth was working at
a nightclub when Gooding approached her.
After denying his advances,
Gooding then proceeded to grope her
several times. Unlike the 2020
suit, the same Page Six report
noted the events that transpired within
the 2019 lawsuit happened a year prior.
In June 2021, Complex reported that Ashworth
won her lawsuit in a default judgment—basically
meaning that Gooding simply failed
to respond to the lawsuit at all.
Even before all the sexual misconduct
allegations against him were revealed,
Cuba Gooding Jr.'s career
wasn't what it used to be.
"Show. Me. The. Money!"
After the success of Jerry Maguire,
Gooding suffered the same career slump that has
plagued many actors after they win an Oscar.
Despite starring in films like the
well-received As Good As It Gets and
the box office hit Pearl Harbor, Gooding's
post-Oscar resume is plagued by a series
of terrible comedies that have landed him
several Golden Raspberry Award nominations.
Some of his more questionable career
decisions included the Eddie Murphy
misfire Norbit, the poorly reviewed and
little-seen Disney comedy Snow Dogs,
and the much-reviled family sequel Daddy Day Camp.
Even with films like the Ridley Scott crime drama
American Gangster in between these mistakes,
it was clear that the days of critically acclaimed
films like Jerry Maguire were long past Gooding.
Gooding has even acknowledged in an interview with
Page Six that he made several bad decisions for
his career, including revealing he turned down
roles in several acclaimed films like Amistad,
Ray, The Last King of Scotland, and Hotel Rwanda,
all of which went on to be
nominated for three Academy Awards.
When asked why he made so
many poor career choices,
Gooding denied that he was
motivated by money. He said:
"For me, it was always about protecting the
sanctity of that golden statue. Because I
felt I needed to show people that
I can do more, I can do better."
After several critical and commercial
failures, Gooding faded from the limelight,
but still managed to get work in the form of
several direct-to-DVD films. In fact, between
the years of 2006 and 2013, Gooding appeared
in almost nothing but direct-to-DVD pictures.
Like many movies that skip the theater,
these films mostly consisted of forgettable
action flicks and lackluster family offerings,
from hardboiled crime films like Wrong Turn
at Tahoe, which also starred a far-fallen
Harvey Keitel, to animated numbers like 2007's
The Land Before Time XIII: The Wisdom of Friends.
After this series of debacles, Gooding
made the jump back to feature films like
the Tuskegee Airmen war film Red Tails and the
Robert Rodriguez-directed flick Machete Kills,
as well as supporting roles in Oscar-nominated
pictures such as Selma in 2014 and Lee Daniels'
star-studded period piece The Butler
(2013). It wasn't exactly a comeback,
but it seemed like a promising
reprieve from all the dreck.
Gooding also made the jump back to television,
with guest appearances in shows like the Fox
hip-hop drama Empire and the short-lived ABC drama
Forever, as well as TV movies like Gifted Hands,
where he played neurosurgeon and
presidential candidate Ben Carson.
"And then I read this screenplay and saw
that he was raised by a single mother
who instilled his faith in God.
And my mom was the exact same way."
While the latter film landed Gooding
a Screen Actors Guild nomination for
Outstanding Performance by a Male Actor in a
Miniseries-slash-TV Movie, none of these film
or television roles lit the entertainment world
on fire the same way Gooding's past projects did.
Many actors retreat from the spotlight in
order to focus on working behind the camera,
something that Gooding tried his hand
at in 2018. Gooding's directorial debut
came in the form of Bayou Caviar, an
action film that he also co-wrote.
In this film, Gooding starred as Rodney
Jones, a retired boxer who gets mixed
up with Russian mobsters and is tasked with
gathering information for a blackmail scheme
against a real estate mogul. The film also
starred Famke Janssen as a photographer who
aids Jones on his quest and the legendary
Richard Dreyfuss as the main mobster.
Despite a strong supporting cast, the
film was not well received by critics.
And considering it came out a year
before the misconduct allegations did,
it's not surprising that he hasn't
stepped back into the director's chair.
Megaproducer Ryan Murphy cast Gooding in
the first season of American Crime Story,
which covered the infamous O.J. Simpson
trial and accompanying media circus.
Gooding was cast as Simpson, the disgraced
former athlete and actor at the center of
the show. Playing Simpson was similar to the
role that made Gooding famous. The actor said:
"I say this is my second stab at
Rod Tidwell from Jerry Maguire,
because both of these personalities
are born from this thing that happens
with athletes [...] One had a positive
outcome and this one had a negative [one]."
Perhaps that's why both Gooding's performance
and the series itself were critically acclaimed;
Gooding even scored an Emmy
nomination for his performance.
"O.J., did you do it?"
"No."
Gooding followed up this well-received
performance with another Ryan Murphy project,
as a main cast member of the sixth
season of American Horror Story,
subtitled Roanoke. Gooding starred
alongside Sarah Paulson as a
married couple terrorized by a group of
killers after moving to North Carolina.
Though not as critically
acclaimed as American Crime Story,
Roanoke still received positive reviews.
Both Ryan Murphy projects brought Gooding
back into the spotlight for a short time,
but they also led to yet another controversial
incident. During a 2017 event promoting his
American Horror Story season, Gooding was caught
lifting up Sarah Paulson's skirt when she got up
to greet actress Kathy Bates at the event. Despite
backlash for his actions, Gooding shrugged it off.
"I see Sarah Paulson as my sister."
After both his runs on American
Horror Story and American Crime Story,
it seemed like Gooding would be hot on the
screen market once again. Instead, he made
a slightly unexpected move with a brief stint
on stage. He'd already appeared on Broadway for
2013's well-received play The Trip to Bountiful,
but had yet to appear in a musical production.
In 2018, he was cast in the London
West End theater revival of Chicago,
playing the role of sleazy defense lawyer
Billy Flynn. A turn on Broadway can showcase
an actor's range while also earning them a good
living, but Gooding said he just wanted to:
"See if I could pull off a
musical. That was the main reason."
Reviews for Gooding's performance, and for the
show overall, were mixed. While certain outlets
like The Guardian gave relatively positive
remarks to both Gooding's performance and
the show as a whole, other reviewers like
London Theatre were much more critical of
the lackluster production value and the
uninspired take on the long-running show.
"I've played ice hockey 20 years.
I've boxed almost professionally.
And nothing prepared me for singing
and dancing eight shows a week."
Gooding's run as Billy Flynn
was short-lived. He concluded
his run on September 1 of that year
before being replaced by Brian Kemp,
though he returned to the role twice
for brief runs in both 2018 and 2019.
The current-day problems that have surrounded
Gooding have stalled his career almost completely.
As of 2021, the only notable film that Gooding
starred in was the 2020 romantic drama film
Life in a Year, which starred Jaden Smith and
Cara Delevingne as teenage lovers who decide to
live their lives to the fullest when Delevingne's
character reveals that she has terminal cancer.
The film held promise; it also starred Nia
Long and RZA, and was executive produced by
Jaden's parents, Will and Jada Pinkett Smith.
But with negative reviews, limited streaming
distribution, and another star accused of sexual
misconduct, the movie was quickly forgotten.
Despite various court appearances and no other
film or television projects on the horizon,
the Daily Mail has reported the actor was
recently seen partying in Los Angeles,
bar hopping and mingling with other patrons.
With another lawsuit pending and many other
allegations still under investigation,
it's safe to say that Gooding won't be
making another comeback anytime soon. With
sexual misconduct allegations being taken more
seriously after the rise of the MeToo movement,
most Hollywood studios wouldn't dare employ
someone as controversial as Cuba Gooding Jr.,
especially with a list of accusers as long as his.
Whether or not Gooding tries to mount a
comeback — either by more Direct-To-DVD films,
another directing gig, or some other form
of entertainment — remains to be seen.
But numerous pending court appearances
will most likely keep him busy for a while.
If you or anyone you know has
been a victim of sexual assault,
help is available. Visit the Rape,
Abuse & Incest National Network
website or contact RAINN's National
Helpline at 1-800-656-HOPE (4673).